meine damen und herren das
infektionsschutzgesetz die novelle und
die frage wie rechts fest ist das ganze
das ist eine frage die man tatsächlich
wirklich nur mit experten bereden kann
mit der wissenschaft deswegen freue ich
mich dass uns aus frankfurt am main
zugeschaltet ist professor uwe volkmann
verfassungsrechtler an der goethe
universität frankfurt am main
ich grüße sie nach hessen herr professor
volkmann und sie haben auch das
vorhergehende gespräch schon mit gehört
wir müssen jetzt noch ein bisschen mal
versuchen das auseinander zu nehmen also
diese novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes wenn wir mit
einer generellen einschätzung einsteigen
wie verfassungsfest ist das aus ihrer
perspektive
man muss die leute vorweg sagen
verfassung funktionieren nicht immer so
dass man sagt das ist jetzt klar
verfassungswidrig oder das ist jetzt
klar verfassungsgemäß das ist anders als
bei der straßenverkehrsordnung die
vorsieht dass man in geschlossenen
ortschaften nicht schneller als 50
fahren und bei 51 ist es daneben
rechtswidrig verbesserung gelegt hat im
grunde immer erst mal so eine meine
richten und orientierungspunkte und sie
geben und symbole eine idee davon wie
lösung geschaffen sein sollen oder
welche verfahren wird er ein bisschen
aber da wir beide gegenseitig
entwicklung muss man doch schon einige
prinzipielle problem
und jetzt müssen wir darüber reden
welche prinzipien probleme das aus ihrer
perspektive jetzt seht also das zentrale
problem das auch in der öffentlichen
diskussion bislang noch gar nicht
angemessen behandelt worden ist ist der
komplette ausfall des rechtsschutzes vor
den verwaltungsgerichten
bislang sind alle maßnahmen entweder
durch rechtsverordnungen der
landesregierungen angeordnet worden oder
durch allgemeinverfügung etwa der
kommunen oder
der landkreise und man hat die
möglichkeit diese maßnahmen vor den
verwaltungsgerichten überprüfen
zurücklassen
nunmehr sollen die beschränkungen
unmittelbar durch das gesetz selbst
angeordnet werden und gegen gesetze gibt
es keine gerichtliche
überprüfungsmöglichkeiten das heißt der
komplette rechtsschutz der bislang
gewährleistet war und auf den wir in der
bundesrepublik auch ein bisschen stolz
waren dass wir sagen also wir haben zwar
diese maßnahmen aber es können gerichte
noch mal drüber schauen sie können sich
das ganze noch mal ansehen und gucken
schießen die über das ziel hinaus in die
grenzen staatlichen handelns gesetzt
sind eingehalten
dieser komplette dieser rechtsschutz
fällt nun komplett aus und das ist doch
meines erachtens ziemlich gefährlicher
präzedenzfall
dieser punkt und wie sie zurecht
anmerken noch nicht angemessen behandelt
auch in der öffentlichen medien arbeit
deswegen tun wir es jetzt hier auch bei
phoenix wenn ich das recht verstehe was
sie gerade angemerkt haben hat das ein
bisschen was zu tun mit der sie
korrigieren mich wenn ich falsch liege
mit der klassifizierung des ganzen
gesetzestextes als ein bundesgesetz
grunde genommen hat uns dann so einen
rang etwa wie ein bürgerliches
gesetzbuch oder 1 strafgesetzbuch und
hat im grunde genommen
deswegen dann auch nicht diese starken
angriffsmöglichkeiten die sie jetzt hier
zu recht also kritisiert haben dass das
nicht möglich ist dass ist auch ein
bisschen das ist der entscheidende punkt
also haben einen namen im grundgesetz
das ist der artikel 19 absatz 4 der sagt
bei angriffen durch die öffentliche
gewalt steht jedem bürger der zugang zu
den gerichten laufen und als öffentliche
gewalt im sinne dieser vorschrift gelten
aber eben nur exekutiv maßnahmen das
heißt also etwa verwaltungsakte oder
auch verordnungen gesetze zählen hier
nicht als aktuelle öffentlichen gewalt
und länder nun die entsprechenden
maßnahmen in gesetzesform gießt dann
werden sie sozusagen dem
anwendungsbereich dieser rechtsschutz
garantie entzogen
ja das ist im grunde das grundproblem
das einzige was man dann als bürger noch
machen kann ist wieder auf die straße zu
gehen wo der protest bereits jetzt
kruden verzerrte formen annimmt oder
sich man kann versuchen sich an das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu wenden
das aber im grunde bei allen maßnahmen
bis jetzt keine eigentlich rechtliche
überprüfung
vorgenommen hat sondern nur eine sehr
allgemeine folgenabwägung und generell
ist es ja so dass wir vom
bundesverfassungsgericht in dieser
pandemie zuletzt ja sagen wir mal
zurückhaltend nicht sehr viel gehört
haben
das bedeutet jetzt wenn wir das noch
einmal ein bisschen runterbrechen auf
die andere ebene die bundesregierung ist
jetzt ein bisschen ins risiko gegangen
sage ich jetzt mal salopp und arbeitet
nach dem motto wo kein kläger da kein
richter
ja das ist ja das ist irgendwas denn
neben diesen regel um das kann man
relativ klar sagen ob man sich das so
auch überlegt hat und dass das ziel war
das weiß ich nicht aber es ist
jedenfalls eine klare folge dieser er
regelt und was man damit letztlich auch
verstehen dass man ja auch wir sehen
also eingerichtet wie entsprechende
verordnung überprüfen kann dann ist das
natürlich einerseits ein korrektiv weil
dem auch mal die eine oder andere
maßnahme gekippt aber er ist sicher die
letztlich auch die legitimität und
akzeptanz dieser maßnahme also die
möglichkeit dass man gerichte anrufen
kann die sich das ganze noch einmal
ansehen und die gerichte schauen dann
halt auch in billigen das eine und hilft
vielleicht die anderen maßnahmen auf das
ist für dafür dass diese maßnahmen auch
weiter in befolgung eingehalten werden
zentral und gerade solche maßnahmen wie
die nächtlichen ausgangssperre wir
können sie nicht ausschließlich mit die
polizei widersetzen weil die wissen im
grunde von den bürgern auch aus einsicht
in die richtigkeit
befolgt werden und für diese einsicht
sind wir richtig überprüfungsverfahren
meines erachtens wissen und das bringt
uns zu unserem letzten punkt das wäre
das gewesen was ich sie hätte auch gerne
noch fragen wollen weil sozusagen meine
nachbarin ihren nachbarn recht
möglicherweise dieses thema
ausgangssperre ganz massiv auf die
oppositionsfraktionen haben das schon
angemerkt sogar teile aus dem lager der
großen koalition und der länder wäre es
jetzt sozusagen angemessen vom
gesetzgeber wenn er in diesem
gesetzgebungsprozess den
parlamentarischen prozess der noch läuft
jetzt also hier nochmal sagt dieses
werden wir noch einmal etwas aufklaren
und anpassen wer das sozusagen aus ihrer
sicht das notwendige ja man muss
überhaupt überleben er kommt diese
ausgangssperren ein sinnvolles und
geeignetes mittel muss ich erst mal das
überhaupt das ziel das machen damit
erreichen sie haben wir entgegen
gesprächen und mit einem klick bald
angesprochen die unterbindung von
kontakten im freien ist kein zufall ist
dann geht es vielleicht während das man
wie dies von den moneymoney 32 oder in
sich laufen die sich irgendwo stecken
ich weiß nicht ob man das wirklich
erinnert oder ob die nicht dann auch
andere wege finden und dafür millionen
leuten zu untersagen 80 oder abends
heraus überlassen 21 muss ja auch im
sommer dennoch hält das vielleicht eben
auch über das ziel hinaus oder geht es
eher darum ein zeichen zu setzen also
den leuten zum signalisiert
die lage ist ernst aber auch dass wieder
eine ein ziel das so weitreichende
freiheitseinschränkung eigentlich nicht
recht die einschränkung von
freiheitsrechten ganz herzlichen dank
dass sie das für uns aufgeklärt haben
professor uwe volkmann war das
verfassungsrechtler goethe universität
frankfurt am main und möglicherweise
finden die treffen dann künftig früher
am abend statt danke und grüße nach
hessen
märz